today we are armed the nation of Iran is
equipped today against the bullies of
the world
Mamu Lobby last night we slapped the
u.s. on the face when it comes to
confrontation military actions of this
kind are not enough what is important is
the corrupt presence of the United
States in this region must come to an
end
they brought war and hostility and
deception and destruction to this region
wherever they go this happens they are
still insisting that this corruption
this destructiveness should be imposed
on Iran the Supreme Leader of Iran
Ayatollah Ali Khamenei giving a pretty
wide-ranging speech there following
those missile attacks on Iraqi targets
for the retaliation of the killing of
Dasom Soleimani he said he talked about
the Iranian Revolution back in 1979
being a pivotal change for the country
and the world he said the Deranian
should use the historical lessons of the
revolution to confront Iran's enemies
today not surprisingly he focused of
course on Qasem Soleimani and he spoke
at length about sulemani he said he had
great character and personality he said
he was a brave warrior a person with
initiative he was sincere and not a
hypocrite he said
sulemani was a very religious man and
drew on his faith he said soleimani
always supported the cause of the
Palestinians in their struggle against
Israel and he said the presence of the
US in the region should and would come
to an end let's go to Assad beg who
joins us live now from the Iranian
capital I said so a wide-ranging and
sobering speech the Supreme Leader
reminding the nation to draw upon the
lessons of the 1979 Islamic Revolution
in confronting Iran's enemies today but
he also had some very lengthy praise for
Qasem Soleimani killed in that US drone
strike yes that's right Qasem Soleimani
was a friend of the supreme leader
Ayatollah Khomeini and what's also
important is it's not usual for the
Supreme Leader's speeches to be carried
live and this one was he also said he
also said that yesterday's missile
attack against US forces
a slap in their face and it was time for
them to leave the region but also
backing up everything that he's saying
he he's giving a theological reassurance
of who the theological foundation to it
he said that having military equipment
isn't enough but he did say that Iran
did possess the military equipment that
would help them stand up to the bullies
and focusing specifically on the United
States he he spoke about how outside
forces are trying to influence people he
spoke about the protests that took place
here in November and how Outsiders are
tried to infiltrate those protests
referring to some of them as rioters and
some of the damage that was done to
buildings here but this is the first
speech after the missile attack against
the United States against the United
States forces and something that the
supreme leader Ayatollah Khomeini had
said that would happen he said that we
would avenge Qasem Soleimani and and his
imagery was used throughout his speech
he saw people in the audience carrying
pictures of Qasim so the money and those
pictures are all over Iran currently and
as we understand that the Iranian
president Hassan rouhani has also been
talking what's he been saying
well he's also been coming out with some
strong words he said that the United
States cut off the hand of gossamer
soleimani
but Iran was cut off their feet and make
sure that the US is ousted from the
region now this is something that's been
echoed from military commanders hear
from the people on the streets asking
for revenge but as far as Iran is
concerned this is the end of the matter
as long as the United States does not
retaliate Iran says that they reacted to
a specific assassination of the general
Qasem Soleimani so they were really
responding to the United States but if
the United States retaliates then Iran
will escalate